well summer is clearly on the horizon
and experts are predicting one of the
biggest summer travel seasons ever we
are getting some game-changing travel
tips from actress and best-selling
author kimberly williams-paisley
if you're hoping to make your next
getaway more enjoyable convenient and
stress-free listen up there's a lot of
moving parts when you're traveling with
a group so i recommend packing the night
before i get my kids to pack themselves
i like to pack creature comforts like an
eye mask and my ear plugs and maybe some
fuzzy socks so that it feels like home
as soon as i get there another thing
that i realized i really appreciate is
having
sweets it's just nice for people to
spread out a little bit and it's not
home without you guessed it good food
hilton has
tons of locations that offer free hot
breakfast there's pancakes by true the
kids love pancakes and waffles they have
hampton by hilton has a waffle machine
i like omelets because i like a good hit
of protein first thing in the morning
but it really helps to have a place in
the hotel it's included in the stay if
you're hitting the road with pets there
are thousands of pet friendly options
learn more and start planning at
hilton.com